[Musique]
la martinique a mal à son chu centres
hospitaliers universitaires une
situation financière sanitaire des
personnels une situation qui a donc
amené à la création de collectifs
officiellement septembre de l'an dernier
le chum 12 ans douvan bonjour marie
jeanne louis léopold bonjour messieurs
veulent tant merci d'être avec nous dans
son caddie vous êtes membre de ce
collectif le chu de martinique est
actuellement sous administration de
trois fonctionnaires de l'igas et
l'expert l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales comment se passe cette
administration selon vous nous sommes au
mois d'avril
oui donc en fait ce sont des
administrateurs qui sont arrivés en
janvier le 3 janvier 2018 et donc du
coup nous on est très satisfaits de la
manière dont il travaille notamment avec
le collectif
nous les rencontrons de manière
hebdomadaire tous les mardis nous les
rencontrons pour travailler pour faire
des propositions pour pouvoir aider à
redresser le chu de martinez glide et à
redresser le chu de bordeaux
qu'est ce que c'est possible pour 7 pour
cette mission dont qui se dont le
travail s'achèvera au mois de juin
oui donc ils sont à mi parcours donc
d'emblée quand ils sont arrivés ils nous
ont dit qu'ils allaient travailler sur
un certain nombre de chantiers qui ce
kit qui parle de la réorganisation de la
réorganisation du chum et qu'il n'allait
pas aller sur un pan de nos deux
incertains de nos revendications comme
notamment le plan financier
sadow crisper un sens vous avez triste
pdg de rouge déjà
déjà parce qu'on avait écrit tout de
suite à la ministre par rapport à la
lettre de mission qu'on leur avait donné
bon ils sont arrivés donc on était prêt
à travailler on est toujours prêts à
travailler vous voyez il faut pas trop
sanguin trop réactif sur la
communication soit aux idées bien sûr
mais il n'empêche que ce que nous étions
un petit peu nous voyons un peu ce qui
allait se produire puisque eux mêmes
dando qu'il ne s'attendait pas à la
partie financière mais il n'empêche
qu'ils devaient travailler à trouver des
fonds des fonds pour la trésorerie pour
le quotidien puisque nous devons 150
millions de dettes fournisseurs et donc
au quotidien les équipes sont handicapés
par le fait qu'ils n'ont pas de moyens
pour travailler
et la directrice était justement de
d'entrée de serrer les boulons pour
tenter de réduire ce déficit alors sur
cette question financière pour la
gestion au quotidien compte il cherchait
à faire comment avez vous réagi
alors ils ont cherché à avoir une ligne
de trésorerie auprès des banques
ils ont cherché donc au niveau de la
caisse d'epargne par exemple on fait
confiance au niveau des deux banques qui
ne l'auront qui ne leur ont pas accordé
les fonds est-ce que vous avez
l'agression est ce que d'autres savent
au niveau chum du vent du vent
est ce que d'autres savent tous qu'ils
soient ses boucles audio pâques habitée
la jad abrite à ces banques là ni opa
cabane où l'agent pucci parce que parce
que là où gaga des bilans les comptes du
chu manque à penser que yo pa tini
konfyans ce malgré le fait que l'ailé
segas l'apathie et aux allées au
ministère et le ministère de capoter
comment des cautions balle je suis
malgré ça les banques papeete donc c'est
vrai qu'actuellement nos ados entre ados
situation qui vraiment qu'ils pas
possible et donc c'est pour ça nous car
aujourd'hui à nous car hypatie au
ministère si nous savons des tours et
des situations actuellement que se
battre a dit en outre ne pas cramer
ténois de rieter exactement exactement
alors été travail les igg assailli shia
est négociée apparemment you paris vi
pas apparemment yop arriver puisque
jodie nous que yo par yves et râper la
jante à la alors qu'est ce qui peut se
passer aujourd'hui parce que il ya eu
cet aspect voulait financier et il ya
également organisation au sein du chu on
sait qu'il y en appel un appel à
candidature a été lancé pour un nouveau
directeur qui devrait entrer en fonction
au deuxième semestre de cette année en
matière d'organisation ce que j'ai
l'impression que des choses bougent un
peu au niveau du chu de martinique oui
les choses ont bougé quand je vous
disais la collaboration et on a changé
donc on avait dans nos revendications
par exemple des poids sur la gouvernance
où aujourd'hui il y a une espèce de
démocratie participative en fait qui
n'est au chu enfin le principe de
réunion le principe de faire remonter
les besoins des services de faire
entendre ce que les gens du terrain
dire on a avancé dessus mais il
n'empêche quand même qu' il y à un
certain nombre de choses qu'ils ont
commencé et que nous voulons voir que
que ça puisse continuer par exemple
exemple ici alors un exemple le
capacitaire le nombre de lits dont
dispose le chu il nous avait été on nous
avait demandé de réduire le nombre de
lits à 2 2 212
je prends si je prends l'exemple de
l'avc qui est un problème en martinique
il ya 30 % des patients un tiers des
accidents cardiovasculaires
un tiers des accidents cardiovasculaires
qui sont qui arrive au chu ne sont pas
hébergés dans les lits qu'il faut savait
dès que les médecins ils sont dans
toutes sortes de services parce qu'il ya
un manque de place dans le service qui
s'occupe des déserts et c'est donc la
neurochirurgie aujourd'hui les igas ont
décidé de revoir ça pour que tous les
avc soit au même endroit et pour donner
beaucoup plus de chances aux patients
l'organisation la seule organisation la
simple organisation pourrait résoudre
bien des problèmes biais des soucis qui
crispe haut niveau au niveau du chu
oui l'organisation pourra résoudre des
choses mais ce qui manque aujourd'hui au
chu surtout pour pouvoir vraiment se
redresser
c'est un souffle le souffle qu'il nous
faut c'est de l'argent et on est obligé
de passer par là parce qu'il manque des
moyens de base pour travailler le moyen
de base c'est-à-dire la boîte de
pansements
j'aimerais diriger réel tel matériel
pour tel service je vous explique je
prends par exemple si vous avez je
prends l'exemple que tout le monde
connaît ça va parler à l'école vous avez
une maîtresse qui est censé dispenser un
savoir à quelqu'un qui passent le bac en
fin d'année qui n'a pas d'un livre qui
n'a pas de tableau qui n'a pas de chaise
bon s'asseoir qui n'a pas de bureau et
on lui demande bien sûr de à la fin de
deux lames qu'aux mondiaux de l'année
deux enfants que celle que les élèves
réussissent au bac à benne nous c'est
pareil on a par exemple dans un service
de diama tôt 6 internes qui sont dans le
service qui on est à un bureau une
chaise qui est délabré et ils sont six
y'a pas d'ordinateur il n'y a pas de
téléphone
pour pouvoir regarder les exams ils ont
eux même acheté une un téléphone
portable de leur poche pour pouvoir être
joints par les urgences quand on l'a on
leur fait on leur fait monter des
patients il vigueur ce que ce qu'elle
dit lorsqu'elle constate ce genre de
situation alors justement les experts
les igas disent qu'il faut entre sens
entre 50 pardon et 150 millions d'euros
pour qu'on puisse sortir de l'eau et
obtenir les moyens de base pour pouvoir
travailler aujourd'hui non pas s'ils
n'ont pas cet argent là aujourd'hui on a
abandonné parce que nous avons recensé
un certain nombre de besoins de y'en a
énormément qu'ils vont chiffrés pour
pouvoir travailler au quotidien pour que
les agents aient des moyens de rendre le
service qui le rendent à la population
est aujourd'hui ce qu'ils ont comme
solution c'est de ne pas payer pendant à
peu près cinq mois les charges sociales
ce qui n'est pas une solution puisque
c'est reculer pour mieux sauter qu'il
n'y aura pas de paiement de charges
sociales pendant cinq mois c'est ce
qu'ils ont pour le moment comme solution
va ajouter une couche sur le
millefeuille exactement on a appris
dernièrement par exemple que le le
service radiologie n'accepterait plus de
rendez-vous externe est ce que ça veut
dire
est ce que ce sont là des conséquences
de ce délabrement de la sentir aussi au
niveau du chu
ce sont des conséquences du délabrement
de la santé mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le service de dermatologie de
radiologie pardon c'est un c'est un
épiphénomène saga qui lie à un armement
de services qui sont dans la même
situation
pourquoi pas sinon ça fait parce que ce
dernier d'autres voilà parce que ça fait
des années qu'il y a de bon il ya des
problèmes internes au service mais il y
a aussi les conditions de travail les
moyens qu'il n'ya pas qu'il faut qu'on a
eu une fuite d'un praticien hospitalier
de médecins qui sont partis parce que
c'est pas possible de travailler dans
des conditions telles et qui font
qu'aujourd'hui le la charge de travail
qui repose sur ceux qui sont restés et
intenable et donc il y à des choix comme
ça qui sont fait qu'on peut qu on
pourrait regretter parce que les
consultations externes en radiologie en
a besoin
les patients n'ont besoin en martinique
mais il n'empêche que voilà et sa faveur
une incidence sur l'attractivité de
notre chu pense que nous sommes folles
universitaire donc de recherche ça
pourrait peut-être avoir une incidence
sur ceux qui voudraient venir travailler
par exemple au sein de ce chu man man ou
léopold en ou pas est diabétique à qui
capable et new hope il puisque
régulièrement sacre à monthey qui dit
côté trinité qui d'écouter leurs
médecins qui atteint eur d'actifs man
ses personnels à you fat e-jets clio
l'ac milan situation de burn-out donc la
faiblesse supplémentaire qui manioc a
senti ce montant puisque pendant qu'à
peine grâce à tignes impulsion à nos
jours oui en fait ben ou la nounou
l'habitude nous kanouni l'habitude
goumba l'hôpital a simplement à
tirlemont nous ça nous laisse cuban où
les moyens de travail
ces cabanes ou les os 4 avayou vous
voilà base au travail c'est sa nou ka
mandé poussé mon nom mé écueil au double
boot
et puis quand nous continuer en service
la noc a maintenant été sacrée somme à
l'automne au cape town à l'extérieur du
chu que la population qu a dit simon
tapas bong l'hôpital t'as pas bon mais
pour un thriller prisca sorti les pieds
devant
oui ça café nous mal parce que l'anuga
gazier bon ni des bag & pack a bien
passé mais saks annoncé qu'elle laissait
kaba gala bien passé mais comme on y est
si ou pas ni les moyens de travail ou
des bonbons service et ça notamment de
ses pouces à noah d'un collectif là
c'est vous ça ne pas qu'amélie est que
nous investit nous investit parce que ça
nous les c'est que bagua il a changé
pour que bon service qu'on a la
population et que nous fier à travailler
travaillant dans l'hôpital talla uni
moun ki ka goumba la population et c'est
très important pour vous de mener cette
information de la population c'est pour
ça que vous multipliez les olé les
réunions d'information auprès de cette
population
oui tout à fait donc nous multiplions
les réunions nous nous sommes constitués
en association sauvé la santé en
martinique
et puis l'association et le collectif
chum douvan douvan rencontre la
population
nous allons d'ici le début du mois de
mai ne doivent rencontrer 2 2
d'allant dans deux communes pour pouvoir
dire tout ça à la population merci
d'avoir été avec nos maris jaloux
léopold rappelle que vous êtes membre de
ce collectif chum du grand merci bonne
journée
merci en vain